great news you have been selected to
participate in the succession war to
determine who will become the next king
of the cocking Empire all you have to do
is look into this here see done and you
will be granted a powerful nan beast
look here it is now and it looks like
your nan beast is a youtube subscribe
button which you can put to use
immediately by subscribing to the new
world review for regular hunt under
content upload it straight into your
YouTube feed good luck in the war hello
and welcome to the new world review your
source for everything anime and manga
and today it's time for some more modern
hunter hunter business as we delve into
a very important yet often overlooked
aspect of the succession war which are
the three main mafia families that
currently control the large majority of
the black whale one and these guys often
get forgotten about what with all the
shiny nen beasts and princes aboard to
focus on but these mafia powers actually
represent some pretty serious business
which is very interesting because none
of the official cocking princes who have
benefactors of these groups you about
nan prior to the commencement of the
succession war so if anything these
mafia factions somehow have more
advanced knowledge than many of the
actual contenders but let's get straight
into them within the underworld of the
Cockaigne empire there are three great
powers that control various black market
operations known as the gu haley and cha
our families respectively at this point
I'd also like to apologize for any
incorrect pronunciation it is a constant
struggle of mine with hunter hunter
which often sports very weird
translations and straight-up bizarre
amortizations but here we are
nonetheless now just because these
groups operate in the underworld does
not mean that they have no connection to
cocking royalty in fact it's quite the
opposite it's more that the cocking
royalty is so overwhelmingly powerful
that they even rule over the more
questionable elements of their empire as
dated before each of these families are
directly tied to a member of the royal
family who act as a benefactor providing
money or various resources in exchange
for that Mafia family acting with their
best interests in mind you know being
given the ability to ask for favors and
such however the connection runs even
deeper than this as each of the three
families also happen to be ruled by an
illegitimate child of a car King King
and in this case illegitimate means
child not produced by an officially
recognized queen these children and
given two long scars over a large area
of their face to permanently mark them
as illegitimate and allowed to live only
on the condition that they never appear
in public or attempt to involve
themselves in Empire politics although
they are very much involved by default
due to essentially having an allegiance
to an official Prince but
look it's a messy situation but diving
into things with our first group the GU
family who were led by a man named Tonio
long bow and yes both his name and his
head are a direct reference to an onion
but O'Neal is the half-brother of the
current king of the cocky Empire now so
be quico ro and his general belief is
that life is one big struggle for power
resources and supremacy as part of this
he believes that the individuals who
possess these features must do
everything they possibly can to protect
themselves from those who do not so
despite being illegitimate he shares a
very royal mentality you could say
speaking of royalty though the GU family
have thought Prince Angley as their
primary benefactor who was the
highest-ranking Prince involved in the
underworld and naturally the GU family
is also the largest faction of the
underworld in terms of both financial
resources and pure manpower or at the
very least they used to be because since
departing on the back we're 1 over 300
GU family members have been killed
within me a few days and while it is
unknown how many members the GU family
have remaining it can be assumed that
it's quite a comfortable amount as the
balance of power has not yet been thrown
into turmoil by the fact they have lost
300 of their staff now despite being the
largest group the GU family are actually
the ones that we have seen the least
representation from in the series thus
far with only three named characters
other than ownio however these three
individuals are rather excitingly or
very proficient nen users and we will
begin with the painfully named Henry big
enough not really classically took Oishi
name here oh my god why do you do this
to me but Henry serves as the underboss
of the family and he has currently been
ordered by O'Neill to find Hisoka who is
allegedly somewhere aboard the ship and
he has also been tasked with
assassinating Marana the leader of the
Haley family we will get to in a bit but
Henry also happens to be a conjurer with
a hot sue known as buyer hazard which
allows him to turn any device or weapon
e touches into a living thing which also
manages to retain its original function
and so for example in the series Henry
has used this to turn guns into snakes
and then to have his new snake guns
murder their former wielders like using
manipulation moving further down the
ranks we have two more highly trusted gu
family members being lynched for Bako
and zacchara custard ii which sounds
delicious but lynch is an emitter with a
hot suit dubbed body and soul which is a
really strange creation whereby she asks
her target a question then proceeds to
punch them which will cause her target
to give an honest answer and if she
punches them multiple times then the
targets expand on their answer so I
guess you could think of it as something
of a truth
as for mr. Custer this man is a
manipulator whose ability is entitled
Bloody Mary
allowing zucchero to freely control his
own blood which means that he generally
needs to fight with an open wound and
also results in him counting an IV
around with him at all times for
practical reasons but that's more or
less what we know of the GU family so
next up we have the hailey family whose
primary benefactor is the ever tear off'
eyeing fourth prince right neck and is
led by marina Prudhoe an illegitimate
child of King nasibi himself now in
stark contrast to the other two families
the Hale League group possesses a mere
23 members including marina who is by
far the youngest leader of the three and
this is because while marina originally
served as a hailey member at some stage
she performed a successful coup usurping
power from the former leader and then
going on to order her new family members
to kill each other until a mere 22 of
them remained now why 22 it's a very
specific number and there is a very good
reason for this as marina is an end-user
whose ability can only be used on a
maximum of 22 people this ability is
called contagion and it is passed on to
a target through Marana saliva at which
point it begins something of a game-like
process whereby every time someone
infected by contagion kills another
person they level up according to who
was killed so at the moment the death of
an online user is worth one level while
an end user is worth 10 levels and
killing an official Prince is worth 50
levels not only that but as the infected
level up so does their aura output and
at level 20 they even automatically
develop their own inability thus in
effect allowing Marana to create a small
army of nen users however it doesn't
stop there because if an infected
reaches over 100 then they themselves
achieve Moranis status and become what
is known as a members zero which allows
them to infect to further 22 people with
their saliva and begin an entirely new
branch of this game and using this
ability Marina is pursuing her own
personal desires to destroy the world
which she perceives as utterly
disgusting in every way so she's a force
of anarchy for the sake of well an acute
and currently we know of at least one
infected who has developed his own
ability who was the weenie and he now
has access to a hot sue named spatial
teleportation and essentially whenever
Lewy knee is locked in a room with but a
single door and no other exit he gains
the power to cut open said room with his
knife and enter an alternate dimension
which allows him to access any location
that he is visited in the past so he's a
very very tricky man to pin down but I
suppose all you would really need to do
is lock him in a room with two doors and
he's
done but unfortunately he's the only
names member of the hey Olli family we
know thus far with the exception of
cashew and so finally we move on to the
cha our family led by Brock Olli
yes Roku Lee I'm sure it probably sounds
much cooler in Japanese maybe but in any
case this family sports 7th Prince loser
s as the benefactor which is very
interesting because from everything
we've seen of him he seems like a pretty
you know chill guy rather than an
underworld overlord but there you go
broccoli however is another illegitimate
brother of King Nelson B and the cha our
family possess roughly two hundred and
fifty members now rather interestingly
while it does appear that the cha family
or at least their higher-ups are
familiar with none none of the Loess far
have presented themselves as an end
users however to compensate for this
they have made a temporary alliance with
a segment of the Phantom troupe
consisting of Fink's Nobunaga and
Phaeton and this is because the Phantom
troupe were effectively framed for the
murder of a member of the cha family
which was conducted by Louie knee by the
way using his spacial teleportation
ability however the spider soon came to
an arrangement with the cha family and
they have offered to kill the
teleporting assassin as well as marina
head of the Haley family in exchange for
passage to tier one of the black whale
which speaking of tiers each of these
families have a domain of tier on the
black whale one with the cha our family
controlling tier 5 the GU family in
command of tier 4 and Haley maintaining
a dominant presence on tier 3
despite this the leaders of each sect
are invited to be housed on tier 1 where
both Anya and broccoli are currently
stationed Mirena does not appear to be
making use of her tier 1 accommodation
and is much more in the thick of things
as a result though each family is
granted a method a passage to tier 1 in
order to relay events to their various
bosses which is why Fink's and Nobunaga
are so keen to be helping out the cha
family so they can skip the other tiers
and move straight on to the good stuff
but back to Moranis for a second because
we're broccoli and ano share a common
view of the world
marinas rise to power very much
threatens to destroy the balance that
they have so carefully maintained to
this point in fact before she went on
her contagion spree the Mafia families
operated with a strict set of rules
including the approval of killings from
the boss both the murderer and the boss
of the victim and that might sound
really strange but it essentially allows
both of the families to get what they
want being a killing for whatever reason
be it revenge or whatnot and then a
request for compensation from the family
who lost one of their members that was
effectively generating revenue from
allowing one of their own members to be
killed
so business really however with over 300
members of the GU family having been
killed and at least
victims on the side of the cha family
these two groups have expressed joint
concerns regarding the actions of the
healthy family and currently holds
something of an informal truce based on
their shared desire for stability and
underworld etiquette and that rather
simply is where we stand at the time of
this recording three great families one
of them on a warpath and so the GU
family is gunning for Moranis head with
their top officers the cha our family
are also focused on killing marina after
engaging the Phantom troupe and Marana
herself is just out to destroy
everything in sight through her
incredibly infectious and inability and
that pretty much does it for our recap
the great Mafia families at play in the
succession war if you enjoyed this video
in the content this channel produced in
general and please do consider donating
to the New World review patreon because
the support of all of you amazing people
is what continues to make this channel
possible and if patron isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helped support this channel and
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun at any time and please do
head over to my disco server where a
wide array of shenanigan ray takes place
on a daily basis and finally please do
comment with your thoughts on the three
great mafia powers this has been the new
world review and I'll see you next time
[Music]
what do you think comes first the end of
one piece well the end of the succession
will arc of Hunter hunter oh I know this
was probably meant as a jerk but it's
actually a tough question because even
though one piece still has half a decade
left at least I'd say it maybe is more
likely to win first it sadly just is
because we have no idea how long the
succession war business will play out
and takashi would really need to kick
things into overdrive in order to end
this incredibly politically complex
environment that he's put together
because honestly even this far into it
he still seems like he's in the stages
of building everything like we haven't
gotten too much of the meat of the
akhiya it's all mostly just intrigue
right now so maybe if tokachi publishes
at least 10 chapters eeeh then the
succession war will end before one piece
but with the disaster as chapter last
year that was 2019 I can at least say
with certainty that one piece will end
unlike Hunter hunter sadly have you ever
watched fairy tale and do you it's a
good anime so fun fact I was originally
reading fairy tale when the very first
chapter was published it was a big fan
of ray of Master which was mushroom his
previous book in fairy tale looked like
a lot of fun and truth be told it was
for a while but I fell out of touch with
it after the arc well DOCSIS is a dick
and betrays the guild that's how fake
Lee I remember those events and I know
that a ridiculous amount has probably
happened since then but I just can't
bring myself to jump back into it
because fairy tale got very formulaic
and if you are familiar with mushroom is
previous style then it is a bit
difficult to expect him to break that
mold who is the best character and why
is it the audio well suppose it's the
audio primarily because he's the audio